You wake up when your body is ready. No
alarm, no schedule, no place you need to
be. You sit up, stretch, and ask
yourself one question. What should I do
today? For 99% of human history, this
wasn't a hypothetical. This was every
single morning for roughly 300,000
years. And the answer to that question
looked nothing like the life you're
living right now. Modern humans spend
about 90,000 hours of their lives
working. That's roughly onethird of your
waking existence dedicated to a job. But
for the overwhelming majority of human
history, jobs didn't exist. There was no
employment, no wages, no boss, no career
ladder to climb. So what did people
actually do all day? Let's start with
what we know for certain. In 1963,
archaeologist Richard Lee conducted a
study that would change how we
understand prehistoric life. He tracked
the daily activities of the Doju Hansi
people in Batswana, one of the few
remaining groups still living in a way
that resembles pre-aggricultural human
life. He found that adults spent about
2.5 days per week acquiring food. That's
roughly 17 hours. The rest of the time
they did whatever they wanted. And
here's the important part. This pattern
shows up everywhere anthropologists
look. The Hadza in Tanzania, the Ach in
Paraguay, the Martu in Australia.
Completely different environments,
different continents. Same result. About
15 to 20 hours per week spent on
survival activities. For context, you
probably work twice that. Now, some of
you are thinking, "But those are modern
people. How do we know ancient humans
lived the same way? Fair question, and
the answer comes from bones. When
archaeologists compare skeletons of
ancient humans to early agricultural
populations, the difference is dramatic.
Farmers were shorter. Their bones show
signs of nutritional deficiency. Their
teeth were riddled with cavities from
grainheavy diets. They had arthritis in
their spines from repetitive labor, and
they died younger. Ancient human
skeletons, taller, stronger, healthier
teeth, less joint damage. Their bones
tell a clear story. They were doing less
repetitive physical labor, not more. But
the most fascinating evidence comes from
something archaeologists found that
shouldn't exist if survival was a
constant struggle. Art. In 1994,
explorers discovered Chauveet Cave in
southern France. Inside were paintings
created roughly 30,000 years ago.
Horses, lions, rhinoceroses rendered
with perspective, shading, and movement.
These weren't crude stick figures. This
was sophisticated art that required
skill, planning, and most importantly,
time. Someone spent hours, maybe days,
deep inside a cave by fire light
painting animals on a wall. Not for
survival, not for food, for beauty, for
meaning, for something to do. In
Blambo's Cave in South Africa,
archaeologists found 100,000-year-old
perforated shell beads, tiny holes
drilled through sea shells, clearly
meant to be strung together as jewelry.
The nearest coastline was 20 km away.
Someone walked 40 km round trip just to
collect shells, then spent hours
carefully drilling holes with stone
tools just to look good. In 2008,
researchers found a 40,000y old flute
carved from a vulture bone in Germany.
Five finger holes, perfectly spaced.
Whoever made this understood music. They
understood pitch. And they spent
significant time crafting it. Not for
hunting, not for defense, for music.
These aren't isolated finds. Across
Europe, Africa, and Asia, archaeological
sites from 100,000 years ago onward are
filled with evidence of decorative
objects. Carefully crafted tools far
more elaborate than necessary for
survival, and items that required hours
of focused work with no immediate
practical benefit. This is what people
did when they weren't securing food.
They created, they decorated, they made
things beautiful. So, let's reconstruct
a day. You wake up around dawn. The fire
from last night is still smoldering.
Someone adds wood. You eat leftover meat
or fish from yesterday. Maybe some nuts
or berries collected the day before.
Breakfast is social. People talk. They
plan loosely for the day. Not because
they have to, because that's what humans
do. Around midm morning, a small group
might leave to hunt or gather. But
here's the key. You don't go every day.
If the hunt was successful 2 days ago
and food is stored, you might not leave
camp at all. You might spend the morning
working on tools, sharpening a spear,
weaving a basket, scraping an animal
hide to make it soft and usable. This
isn't work in the modern sense. There's
no clock, no supervisor. You do it
because competence matters. Because
being skilled earns respect, because
making things well is part of being
human. If hunting happens, it's not the
frantic chase you see in movies. Humans
are persistence hunters. We track
animals at a steady jog for hours until
they overheat and collapse. We're the
only species that can do this
effectively because we can sweat and
regulate our body temperature while
running. Most animals can't, so we
outlast them. The hunt might take 3 to 6
hours, including travel. Then the animal
is carried back and butchered. Everyone
eats. And by early afternoon, the
productive part of the day is
essentially over. What happens next is
what modern people find hardest to
understand. Nothing and everything.
People rest. They sit in the shade and
talk. They play with children. They
groom each other, picking through hair,
reinforcing bonds. They make jewelry
from shells or beads or animal teeth.
They carve designs into bones or stones.
They nap. Anthropologist James Susman
documented that among the Juwansi,
adults spend roughly 6 hours per day in
what he called social time. not working,
not sleeping, just being with other
people, talking, laughing, telling
jokes. Because in a world without money
or police or written contracts, your
survival depends entirely on your
relationships. If people don't like you,
they don't have to share food when
you're hungry. So, you invest enormous
amounts of time in those bonds. Not
because it's productive, because it's
how humans stay human. Then, the sun
sets, and this is when something
remarkable happens. In 2014,
anthropologist Paulie Weezner analyzed
hundreds of hours of conversation
recordings from the Zhu Huanzi. During
the day, conversations were practical.
Who saw animal tracks where? Which
plants were ready for harvest?
Complaints about someone not sharing
fairly. But at night around the fire,
81% of conversations shifted to stories.
Myths about how the world began, tales
of ancestors who did impossible things,
jokes that made everyone laugh,
adventures from far away. Visner argued
that this is where human culture was
actually born. Gods, spirits, the past,
the future, things you can only think
about when your stomach is full and
you're safe. And people didn't go to
sleep and stay asleep the way you do
now. Historical records from medieval
Europe and sleep studies from the 1990s
confirm that before artificial light,
humans slept in two phases. First sleep
for about 4 hours, then a wakeful period
of 1 to 2 hours in complete darkness,
then second sleep for another 4 hours.
So, here's what a full day looked like.
About 4 to 6 hours securing food or
making tools. About 6 hours in social
interaction, storytelling, grooming,
playing about 8 hours sleeping in two
separate phases, and the resting,
sitting, watching clouds, doing nothing
in particular, existing without needing
to justify your existence through
productivity. Then, about 10,000 years
ago, something changed. Humans in the
fertile crescent began planting seeds
and domesticating animals. agriculture
and agriculture is a trap. Once you
start farming, you can feed more people.
More people means you need more food.
More food means more farming. Within a
few generations, populations exploded
and there was no going back because now
there were too many mouths to survive by
hunting and gathering. You were locked
in. And farming required far more labor.
Plowing, planting, weeding, harvesting,
storing, defending crops from animals
and raiders. The skeletal evidence is
unambiguous. Early farmers worked
harder, ate worse, and died younger than
the hunter gatherers who came before
them. But the population kept growing.
And with larger populations came
specialists, toolmakers, potters,
weavers, inventors, then soldiers,
priests, administrators, and eventually
jobs, employment, the idea that your
time belonged to someone else in
exchange for resources. By the time we
built cities, the original human
lifestyle was gone, replaced by
schedules, obligations, the need to work
most of your waking hours just to
survive in the system we created. Today,
you spend 90,000 hours working. Your
ancestors spent way less. You sleep in
one block and call waking up at 2:00
a.m. insomnia. They slept in two phases
and used the middle hours for
reflection. You spend your life chasing
an illusion of greatness, achievements,
wealth, and success by standards society
invented. They woke up every morning
already free, already enough and at
peace with nothing to prove to anyone.
They didn't need to become successful.
They were already living the life you're
working your entire existence to retire
into. You make art if you can find time
after your job. They made art because
they had time. And that's what humans
do. We're not a different species, but
we live so differently from how humans
lived for 99% of our existence that we
might as well be. We traded freedom for
food security, leisure for population
growth, time for productivity.